fsb cia
do you think a kgb agent would kill
someone against international law if
they were ordered to do so so we talked
about they did
they did
uh and there's uh there's a
famous uh case of uh one uh
uh
i think it's vasily kuklov
who defected he was a killer he was a
train killer and he
had
done assassinations in other countries
he was sent to west germany to kill a
defector a kgb defector and he decided
not to do it
he he talked to the guy and he said i'm
supposed to kill you i'm not and then
then he eventually wound up in the
united states i have a connection to
this fellow because the kgb once
asked me to go to california and see if
the guy still lives and works there
and
we
i found him
and we
looked at each other
so there was an active kgb agent
looking at a man that he didn't know was
the the kgb defector looking at each
other neither one knew who the other one
was i i found out later
but he was able to survive
yes
and you know that there have been
assassinations
not not a lot and uh
you know that that we know of
a good point this is very difficult uh
the the the question is how many lines
are intelligence agencies
willing to cross
to attain
to achieve the goal i
i i think none of these agencies have
the ultimate line i i think eventually
the last line will be crossed if
they believe it's necessary
well i think you can justify a lot of
things especially in this modern world
with nuclear weapons that you can
justify that you're saving the world
actually
you